>>> WITH US IS COLONEL CEDRIC
LEIGHTON.
300,000 NEW TROOPS, ALBEIT
RESERVISTS, PEOPLE ALREADY
INSIDE RUSSIA.
WHAT AND WHERE WOULD THEY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ON THE BATTLEFIELD IN
UKRAINE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
IT DEPENDS ON THE KINDS OF
TROOPS THEY'RE GOING TO BRING
INTO THIS BATTLE SPACE OF
UKRAINE HERE.
REALLY COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE
WOULD POTENTIALLY BE IN THESE
AREAS RIGHT HERE.
WHAT THEY MIGHT DO IS MIGHT BE
USED TO SECURE THESE PARTICULAR
AREAS.
THIS, OF COURSE, IS WHERE
UKRAINE HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
GAINS SO THEY'D HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME IN THIS AREA BUT WHAT THE
RUSSIANS CAN DO, ONCE YOU GO
INTO THESE AREAS THAT THEY
CONTROL, IN ESSENCE, THE LAND
BRIDGE FROM THIS PART OF RUSSIA,
ALL THE WAY TO CRIMEA, RIGHT
DOWN HERE, THOSE ARE THE AREAS
THEY COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE IF
THEY ARE THE RIGHT SPECIALTY,
INFANTRY TROOPS, TANK TROOPS,
ARMORED PERSONNEL DRIVERS, AND
ALSO, INFANTRY FOLKS.
SO THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
AND KINDS OF CAPABILITIES THEY'D
BE LOOKING AT AND PRIMARILY USED
HERE UNLESS PUTIN WANTS TO DO
SOMETHING THROUGH BELARUS OR
THIS PART OF RUSSIA.
WE DON'T SEE MOVEMENT LIKE THAT
BUT THAT IS OF COURSE
POSSIBILITIES FOR RUSSIA'S
MOVEMENT.
>> ONE THING WE'VE HEARD IS THAT
PUTIN MAY BE EXTENDING THE
TROOPS ALREADY ON SERVICE.
WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO MORALE.
IF YOU'RE A RUSSIAN SOLDIER
SERVING IN UKRAINE ALREADY, IN
RETREAT AND THERE LONGER THAN
YOU THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE.
WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO MORALE IF
YOU'RE TOLD YOU CAN'T GO HOME?
>> THAT DESTROYED MORALE.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IN THE EAST.
THE RUSSIANS ARE TRYING TO MOVE
INTO THIS AREA HERE, AND WHAT
THEY WOULD BE DOING IS TRYING TO
ADVANCE THESE FORCES.
SO YOU'RE TRYING TO ADVANCE
FORCES WHO ARE TIRED, WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THIS FIGHT FOR MONTHS
NOW, FOR SEVEN MONTHS OR MORE,
AND REMEMBER, THEY WERE STANDING
THERE EVEN IN DECEMBER.
SO YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A BUNCH
OF TROOPS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY TIRED WHEN IT COMES
TO DOING THIS KIND OF THING AND
TRYING TO RESPOND TO THE
UKRAINIAN OFFENSIVES HAPPENING
HERE.
AND ALSO HERE IN THE SOUTH.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE TRYING TO GO
HERE.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE TO STOP THEM
IF THEY HAVE ANY HOPE OF TRYING
TO DO ANYTHING HERE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH THING
FOR THEM TO DO AND VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE RUSSIANS TO
GET TO THAT POINT.
>> AND THE RESERVISTS, THERE'S
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR READINESS.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT'S A KEY THING.
WHEN YOU'RE PLANNING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
YOU WANT TO BE SURE YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO JUST LEFT THE
MILITARY.
PEOPLE WHO COME INTO SPECIALTIES
THEY CAN USE, EVERYTHING FROM
I.T. TO LOGISTICS SPECIALISTS,
WHICH THEY WOULD NEED A LOT OF.
MY FEELING IS THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE A TOUGH TIME FILLING THE
RANKS AND DOING IT AS QUICKLY AS
THEY NEED TO.
>> ONE THING YOU HEAR FROM NATO,
THEY SEE THIS AS A SIGN OF
WEAKNESS OF RUSSIA.
THERE IS ALSO THIS NUCLEAR
THREAT.
VERY DIRECT NUCLEAR THREAT WHERE
PUTIN IS SAYING IF YOU VIOLATE
RUSSIA'S INTEGRITY, THERE MAY BE
A RESPONSE.
NOT BLUFFING.
HOW SERIOUS DO YOU TAKE THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE REFERENDUM
IN THE AREAS YOU HAVE SHADED
THERE WHICH WILL LIKELY VOTE,
ALBEIT A SHAM VOTE, TO JOIN
RUSSIA WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THESE AREAS RIGHT HERE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT, THESE ARE THE
AREAS, THERE ARE FOUR OF THEM TO
INCLUDE THE DONBAS REGION, AS
WELL AS AREAS THAT THEY'VE
CAPTURED AS PART OF THIS LAND
BRIDGE.
THESE ARE THE AREAS FROM KHERSON
UP TO THE NORTH IN THE LUHANSK
AREA THEY'RE THE ONES VOTING ON
THE REFERENDUM.
WHEN PUTIN MADE THE STATEMENT
HE'S GOING TO PROTECT RUSSIAN
TERRITORY, HE'S GOING TO PROTECT
THIS PART IN ADDITION TO THIS,
THE LARGE EXPANSE OF THE RUSSIAN
LAND MASS.
SO DOING THAT, HE IS SAYING THIS
IS MINE.
NATO'S REACTION TO THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE FAVORABLE AND THE
RISK OF ESCALATION AS A RESULT
OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
>> COLONEL CEDRIC LAYTON GREAT
TO HAVE YOU ON, THANK YOU FOR
LETTING US SEE WHERE THIS IS